حياه الفنانين ما مليئه بالدراما والجمهور
جزء لا يتجزا منها فهو يرغب باستمرار في
معرفه اخبار النجوم المفضلين ويعلق عليها
وينتقدها في بعض الاحيان مثلا الفنانه منه
شلبي اثارت اثمتها الاخيره الكثير من
الانتقادات بعد الحكم عليها على خلفيه
اتهامها باحراز مخدر الحشيش بقصد التعاطي
وضجه مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي في مصر
بصوره نشره الفنان احمد الفيشاوي مع ابنه
بعد ان اعترف بناسبه الاخيره الامر الذي
فتح الباب لتعليقات متابعيه وتحدثنا البعض
عن قصه قديمه تؤكد ان لديه ابن من سيده
المانيه رفعت دعوه قضائيه قبل عامين تطالب
خلالها باثبات سميث
هو انتقادات كثيره اثارتها الفنانه شيرين
باخباري زواجها وطلاقها وحلاقه شعرها
وتعتها المخدرات وخلافاتها مع عائلتها
ووعدت الجمهور بانها ستكون اكثر حرسان
وتكتما في حياتها الشخصيه لحظات صعبه ايضا
عاشتها ذره زروق عقبه زواجها من رجل اعمال
هاني سعد بعدت الدوله الكثير من الشائعات
انه لم يطلق زوجته الاولى مما يعني ان
النجم التونسيه ستكون الزوجه الثانيه وهو
ما يجرمه القانون التونسي ما جعلها عرضه
الكثير من الانتقادات حتى نفذت ذلك